hello everybody and welcome to my
free-to-play speedrun challenge today
we're going to be buying from shops all
over runescape for one hour
the rules are it's gonna be totally free
to play so we're gonna stay into
free-to-play worlds the whole time we're
gonna start with 1 GP at the start and
we're gonna see how much we can get to
using the grand exchange and we'll tally
it up at the end and yeah let's just get
right into it here so the timer started
and I will talk to you guys at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we're done
so the hours up and we just sold off all
the feathers we had to the last night
that we had and we'll take the final
tally so it is a hundred and forty-one K
that's really good that is almost double
my best speedrun previously I know I did
get really lucky in the beginning with
the team capes I actually found the dude
really quickly I mean wanders everywhere
so I surprisingly found him in this old
one for like one cage which is super
lucky that really helped kind of quick
in the process but still I think anyone
could do it and I'd had a lot of fun
doing this I did it about three times to
get that amount and yeah so it's really
not that hard to make money buy from
shops and that's my best if you think he
could beat me I'd really love if you
guys posted a video of you guys doing it
or just tell me what you managed to get
I think it's kind of fun having a bit of
a challenge
of course this isn't the best money
making method by any means but I love on
anything alright thanks for tuning if
you enjoyed it that subscribe button
I'll see you guys next time
[Music]